[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission des
mx1 open et qui terrorisés pour la
première fois sur la nouvelle piste des
clayes-sous-bois ce dimanche plus de 400
concurrents jouer des coudes pour
remporter cette compétition les détails
dans cette édition
tir à l'arc la un concours sélectif
salle au championnat 2.7 et programmées
tout au long du week-end au gymnase
pierre de coubertin de montigny le
bretonneux
la compétition organisée depuis 2012
marque le début de la saison en salle
dans le département nous y reviendrons
dans quelques instants
golf les capitaines de la ryder cup sont
allés à la rencontre de la presse ce
mardi à paris à l'occasion du one year
to go événement qui enclencha dernière
ligne droite de l'organisation de la
compétition sur les greens du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
ils ont dévoilé une partie de leur
stratégie à cette occasion on commence
tout de suite
ce magazine par les résultats sportifs
du dha semaine dans le département
[Musique]
avant de développer ses titres direction
les championnats d'europe de cyclisme
sur piste qui se sont tenues la semaine
dernière à berlin équipe de france a
réalisé une superbe compétition
remportant huit médailles dont cinq en
or
parmi les principales sensation
sébastien vigier le pistard qui
s'entraîne presque tous les jours sur la
piste de saint quentin en yvelines a
remporté à seulement 20 ans la plus
belle des médailles en vitesse
individuelle et s'est également illustré
en montant sur la plus haute marche du
podium en vitesse par équipes avec les y
montrent un quentin lafargue et benjamin
edelin le trappistes benjamin thomas
quant à lui a raflé l'or sur l'épreuve
de poursuite par équipes lors sur
l'américaine et le bronze sur l'épreuve
de l'omnium à cinq points de l'espagnol
albert torres dans la dernière journée
les chez les filles mathilde de gros
obtenu la médaille d'argent en vitesse
individuelle
battus en finale par l'allemande
kristina vos gueules la seule médaille
chez les féminines on continue à parler
de cyclistes et plus précisément de bmx
le club des clayes-sous-bois organisait
ce dimanche sont tous première open sur
sa nouvelle piste
un équipement ouvert officiellement
depuis début septembre plus de 400
concurrents tenter de dompter ces
nouvelles boss les images sont signés à
nicolas landry des coups de pédales sur
vitaminée de la bagarre dans les virages
bienvenue sur l'open de bmx et des
clayes-sous-bois ce dimanche 22 octobre
plus de 400 biker se sont donné rendez
vous pour participer à cette compétition
amicale le niveau les régionales mais il
ya aussi nationale on a des pilotes qui
viennent d'autres départements et même
d'autres régions on a
des pilotes
qui sont allés aux championnats du monde
qui ont fait les
des manches de coupe du monde et du coup
tout ça est allé en tout temps cette
compétition également permis aux biker
de tester la toute nouvelle piste du
club inauguré début septembre plus d'un
million d'euros ont été investis pour
créer un tracé de 350 mètres homologué
par les instances fédérales
après quelques tours de piste premier
verdict à lui coule franchement à
l'élastique nickel et roulantes virage
son propre donc
on fait au max on prend comme on veut
technique et pas trop dangereuse les
virages sont bien compliqué à
appréhender
mettez c'est ça qui est marrant pour
dompter les bosses les 400 participants
tous leurs propres techniques par
exemple sur dans les virages sur les pas
les parties plat bien relancé et bien
pousser sur dix qui a enroulé tout ça
mais bon soit à ses plus grosses il faut
bien et techniques faut pas taper fois
de préciser un repérage de la piste qui
pourrait faire la différence lors de la
prochaine édition 2010 8 l'événement
sera cette fois-ci officielle et
comptera pour le classement général
une fois n'est pas coutume nous allons
parler de tir à l'arc dans ce magazine
un concours sélectif salle au
championnat de france les programmées
tout au long du week-end à montigny le
bretonneux
une compétition organisée depuis 2012
qui marque le début de la saison en
salle dans le département à montage de
sandrine fontaine compter le parfum de
la compétition étaient présents gymnase
pierre de coubertin de montigny le
bretonneux ce samedi 21 et ce dimanche
22 octobre le club marché de la ville
organise un concours sélectif salle au
championnat de france
pour participer les 250 sportifs doivent
avant tout passer par le contrôle du
matériel
donc on ne peut pas avoir de devises eur
qui marque un point sur les cibles par
exemple c'est interdit on doit avoir une
corde qui n'a pas de plus de marques que
les points d'ancrage on doit avoir une
palette qui soit propre et non avec
aucune
distinction supplémentaire les flèches
doivent être marquées une fois le
matériel enregistré des compétiteurs
peuvent prendre le départ et décoché
leurs flèches
les archers peuvent choisir entre les
catégories art classique ou arc à
poulies un matériel moderne qui utilise
un effet de levier
comme son nom l'indiqué qu'on a de
pouline en ruine en bas contrairement
aux art classique les poulets comment
les voiles sont pas axés donc ce qui
permet de démultiplier la force c'est à
dire que quand on va quand on va armer
l'arc ou au moment du passage du pic on
va avoir une puissance qui est au
maximum en france autorisé de 60 livres
on a ce qu'on appelle une bascule et là
j'ai plus de puissance par contre là au
moment du pic là j'en ai beaucoup
là j'en ai plus arc à poulies ou arc
classique les compétiteurs doivent
prendre leurs repères pour être le plus
précis possible sur le départ pour
réussir à toucher la cible installé à 18
mètres chaque participant à sa routine
moi personnellement c'est de bien mettre
ma main dans le gris peu c'est de bien
baissé mon épaule parce qu'il faut que
je travaille ce point là de manière
importante
mais oui on a tout seul une séquence et
des points des points clés à ne pas
oublié dans notre dans notre séquence de
tir une bonne préparation et puis à une
certaine une certaine répétition dans
les gestes
si possible et même ce qui est beaucoup
plus difficile
les archers qui ont fait les meilleurs
scores pendant les deux jours de
compétition seront sélectionnés sont les
quotas aux championnats départementaux
régionaux et championnat de france dans
les différentes catégories de poussins à
super vétérans les deux archers que vous
avez vu pendant le reportage en terminer
premiers de leur catégorie nicolas
vachette de sarcelles a terminé premier
en arc à poulies avec un total de 561 de
son côté à jean luc armand de manila
mois remporté la compétition arc
classique avec un score de 548 du
football à présent avec le championnat
r4 trappe jouer ce week-end contre
maisons alfort à l'extérieur à
l'occasion de la 6e journée du
championnat et les trappistes se sont
inclinés 1 à 0 une désillusion après
leur victoire 4 à 0 contre le leader
ozoir la semaine dernière au classement
trappe redescend la 6e place avec un
bilan de 3 victoires et 3 défaites
depuis le début du championnat
en rugby à plaisir emporté peut-être
l'un de ses matches les plus importants
de la saison en fédérale 2 à la lutte
pour le maintien les plaisirs oies se
sont largement imposés contre un
concurrent direct
arras sur le score de 29 à cette
première victoire de la saison très
bonne opération au classement plaisir
sort de la zone de relégation
l'équipe est 10e sur 12 avec quatre
défaites et une victoire depuis début
septembre on reste à plaisir mais nous
allons maintenant parler de handball les
plaisirs ou en réalisé une très belle
performance dans le championnat de
nationale 3 en venant à bout de l'élite
val d'oise sur le score de 29 à 28 les
victoires acquises dans les dernières
secondes et qui permet au club d'occuper
la sixième place du classement et d'être
en bonne position pour se maintenir en
fin de saison
l'objectif annoncé enfin a toujours en
bas l'équipe féminine de montigny le
bretonneux encore été battus ce week-end
dans le championnat de nationale 2 les
féminines de dénis cholet se sont
inclinés 25 à 22 contre harnes à
l'extérieur au classement rien ne va
plus les signé montaigne sont la
lanterne rouge du championnat avec 1 5
points inscrits depuis le début de la
saison un bilan très compliqué de quatre
défaites pour un match nul
on continue à parler de handball une
nouvelle entente vient de voir le jour
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines elle concerne les jeunes du
secteur pour en savoir plus nous
recevons sur ce plateau laurent le
trionnaire dirigeants de la structure
oui
un crève coeur frieden le capitaine et
damir insu à l'entraîneur bonsoir alors
pourquoi avez vous décidé de lancer
cette structure cette année alors on
très simple on a choisi de lancer cette
structure c'est pour offrir une offre
haut niveau aux garçons de 16 17 et 18
ans le but c'est de créer une entente là
elle plus forte hausse il va falloir
rire les droits en fin de saison de
postuler à une place en championnat de
france -18 voilà d'amiens pourquoi avoir
décidé de wade est le premier coach de
cette structure
alors le but i il est avant tout comme
le dit laurent de créer une entente
forte pour pour les jeunes de cet âge là
et surtout pour garder nos jeunes qui
dès l'âge de 15 16 ans partent dans les
grosses structures le psg massy handball
et surtout d'alimenter au fur et à
mesure donc la nationale 3 de plaisir la
prénationale de de versailles et de
pouvoir s'alimenter en interne et non
pas d'aller recruter des joueurs à
l'extérieur donc on est enfin moi
personnellement je suis en travail très
souvent avec victor garrigues et
entraîneur de la nationale 3 guido et
qui est déjà là s'entraîne deux fois par
semaine avec la nationale 3 alors qu'il
n'a que 16 ans et ils sont quatre
finales 3 de plaisir plaisir oui ils
sont déjà quatre dons dans son cas et
c'était une décision réfléchie
laurent ça me faisait plusieurs mois que
vous en parliez entre vous ça fait
plusieurs mois
c'est une erreur années peut-être
plusieurs années où il sait ce que je
veux dire une entente qui renaît sur les
cendres de feu la team 78 qui avait
malheureusement dû cesser son existence
l'année dernière et on s'est très vite
rendu compte que pour pouvoir offrir
cette offre là aux garçons aux joueurs
on est obligé de passer par la voie
d'une entente s'est passé pas une
situation qui est pérenne pour tel ou
tel club
une année vous pouvez être brillant sur
une génération d'âge et l'année d'après
vous allez être moins fort donc pour
faire une entente et une équipe
championne de france et rennes il était
obligatoire que qu'on se rassemble et
qu'on mutualisent nos forces
ces différents clubs où elle allait
pourquoi vous avez voulu participer à ce
grand projet qui va se mettre en place
tu trouves lui sur je regardais quand
j'étais plus petit la team 7,8 ça me
faisait rêver de voir des affaires est
vraiment j'ai voyagé je vais être à leur
place
du coup je dirais que résister damien
comment se fait la sélection de cette
équipe la sélection s'est fait l'année
dernière en fin de saison on a fait un
tournoi avec les meilleurs éléments tous
les clubs il y avait 40 n 2
d'adolescents et du coup j'ai
sélectionné 25 joueurs à peu près pour
après refaire des entraînements tout le
mois de juin pour créer un groupe et au
final ils sont un groupe de 22 joueurs
pour 12 places
le week end donc on a un groupe qui est
quand même assez important et la chance
que j'ai c'est sur les 22 joueurs les
vingt deux peuvent jouer le week-end
alors c'est très dur des fois parce que
la sélection est rude mais pour le
moment ça se passe super bien et tout le
monde adhère au projet et on le voit
depuis le début de saison n'est dit
victoire et un match nul c'est
c'est très intéressant vous avez été le
seul décisionnaire dans les choix dans
le choix vous si ce joueur oui j'étais
tout seul et n'a rejeté sur le tournoi
de détection et avec philippe étrange
qui était entraîneur de mancini handball
soit installé à quelques années qui m'a
aidé à apprendre un peu plus de décision
mais sur la décision de tous les joueurs
j'ai été tout seuls à choisir
du côté des joueurs ça vous met pas un
peu trop la pression gwénolé de savoir
que vous êtes les les meilleurs
finalement du secteur bah oui et non en
soi non vous avez vous attendu forcément
peut-être mais c'est pas pour autant que
l'on se met la pression forcément parce
qu'on veut ou veut montrer ce qu'on est
capable de faire mais qui n'ont pas
spécialement vous a gagné quasiment tous
vos matches depuis début la saison 10
victoires je crois et un match nul que
ça et l'objectif c'est quoi finalement
laurence et de d'alimenter les équipes
du secteur comme monty bretonneux
plaisir exactement c'est ça le but c'est
que c'est que nos jeunes partent le
moins possible parce qu'il a toujours
qui seront peut-être on le souhaite un
très un très haut niveau national et là
effectivement ça partira jouer dans des
clubs professionnels
mais pour la grande majorité des joueurs
le but c'est que suivant le suivant leur
niveau ils puissent aller
après renforcer les équipes seniors pour
l'instant ces plaisirs et plaisir qui
est en nationale 3 versa qui est en pré
nationale et montigny qui étend en
honneur régional en fonction de leur
niveau atteint jeu en ce qu'on espère
c'est que c'est que nos jeunes s'ils
peuvent rester sur la région après pour
leurs études ils aillent renforcer ces
clubs là où il allait il faut du temps
pour que l'équipe prenne forme
à votre avis n'en faut et l'info mais
après elles sont trois formes quand même
assez vite parce que dès le début on est
on est une bonne des potes quand même et
ça se remarque je pense dans les matchs
on soutient toujours unie solidaire et
une bonne ambiance boursière vos matchs
se disputent par contre dans toutes les
communes finalement qui participent au
projet est ce que ça ne vous déstabilise
pas au niveau de l'effectif
ben pour le monde avait joué par exemple
un plaisir le week-end dernier
pour l'instant on n'a joué qu'un plaisir
à versailles parce que par rapport aux
dates de championnat c'est on ouvre on
savait lundi ce qu'on recevait ou pas
pour le week-end mais après ça va jouer
sur les cinq communes qui rayent
l'encours maurepas voisins-le-bretonneux
mancini versailles et plaisir après
comme on généralement essai de centre et
même pendant les vacances un peu partout
donc c'est pas grave c'est vrai qu'on
peut dire on n'est pas vraiment à
domicile parce qu'on n'est jamais
vraiment au même endroit mais mais au
contraire c'est c'est un événement pour
tous les clubs
quand je vois il encore maurepas qui est
une petite structure de recevoir
l'entente qui j'espère les prochaines
tranches par la france un grand
événement pour eux donc il faut le
prendre plus comme ça que plutôt saisir
on n'est pas forcément à a2micile si
c'est une contrainte qu'on sait qu'on
s'est un peu fixé entre entre dirigeants
et avec les joueurs on a choisi
peut-être de les mettre un peu dans
l'inconfort de pas avoir vraiment une
salle à domicile mais si on veut que
l'entente est une réalité concrète et
une existence bien réelle pour les
différents membres
il faut qu'on aille à tour de rôle joué
à plaisir à montigny à versailles
elancourt et voisins manière ce que tout
le monde ait bien conscience que dans
quelques années les enfants ces deux
villes lac est ok on peut être deux
trois ans de moins peuvent intégrer
l'entente et peuvent ça peut devenir une
réalité pour eux voilà merci à tous les
tourrades être passé sur ce gâteau vous
souhaite beaucoup de réussite sportive
avec cette nouvelle structure qui vient
de se créer au niveau de saint quentin
en yvelines
merci beaucoup merci à tous les trois
hameaux de golf à présent à moins d'un
an de l'organisation de la ryder cup en
france au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lé capitaine
thomas bjorn pour l'europe et jimmy
fricke pour les états unis ont continué
mardi la promotion de l'événement auprès
du grand public après avoir rencontré
les redites lundi dernier des enfants
sur le parcours du golf national ils ont
participé à une conférence de presse car
unis et les journalistes du monde entier
un montage de exigea opération séduction
autour de la ryder cup 2018 ce mardi 17
octobre lever du soleil les deux
capitaines de la compétition jim furyk
et tomates bio m'ont tapé quelques
balles du haut du premier étage de la
tour eiffel devant les caméras quelques
heures plus tard dans un hôtel parisien
les golfeurs ont lancé officiellement
les hostilités lors d'une conférence de
presse c'est le top départ du raz du
ryder cup 2018 c'est maintenant les
capitaines se rend compte que c'est du
sérieux que ils ont une équipe a formé
dans la salle des dizaines de
journalistes venus du monde entier la
conférence a notamment été retransmise
en direct sur les grandes chaînes de
télévision américaines et britanniques
c'est un événement énorme c'est
l'événement le plus important pour le
golf à l'échelle mondiale sans aucune
question possible c'est un événement qui
passionne les foules en grande bretagne
c'est le 3ème 4ème évènement le plus
important le plus suivi au monde
et là on a l'impression que les français
sont en train de découvrir tant mieux il
reste encore onze mois pour que la
france l'approprient sur le plan sportif
pas de grandes annonces pendant ces
trente minutes de questions-réponses
l'américain jim furyk a tout de même
annoncé compter sur la super star tiger
woods si ce dernier avait le feu vert
des médecins
du côté des européens thomass bjorn a
prévenu qu'aucun golfeur n'avait sa
place assurée dans l'équipe y compris
les français il faut pas je pense qu'il
a été clair
espérez vous attendre à une
comment dire un choix wild card naturel
pour un français après jean van de velde
et thomas levet victor dubuisson un
quatrième français sera-t-il sur les
greens du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines du 28 au 30
septembre 2018
réponse dans onze mois après ce
reportage ryder cup on continue à parler
de golf dans ce magazine avec le premier
open tv 78 organise en partenariat avec
la fédération française événement était
programmée vendredi dernier sur le golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines 30
équipes de deux joueurs se sont
affrontés sur les greens de l'albatros
la sortie de ce rendez-vous notre
journaliste patrice carmouze était l'un
des organisateurs avait été avec l'un
des organisateurs laurent basauri nous
dresse le bilan de cette première
édition
or voici un petit bilan plutôt réussie
opération tout à fait réussi d'abord
avec une météorologie qui est absolument
favorables extraordinaire pour jouer au
golf
les participants je crois heureux un
parcours qui a été préféré aux petits
oignons par le golf national des des
compétiteurs
bien qu'ils se sont montrés à la hauteur
de ce parcours qui ont pris je crois
beaucoup de plaisir et qui ne s'est
annoncé qu'elle était préparée aux
petits oignons clubs l'ont dit pour être
compliqué difficile et que tout le monde
puisse s'amuser aussi bien les golfs les
golfeurs on va dire un peu moins
aguerris que les plus aguerris de ceux
qui ont le plaisir d'inviter ce beau
sport
l'intégralité de l'interview sera
retrouvée dans le prochain à part 78 une
deuxième édition sera reprogrammé les 23
et 24 mars 2018
on ouvre à présent une page sport
automobile dans ce magazine nous allons
revenir sur la très belle performance du
jeune gluant courtois hadji milhas à 8
ans il a réussi à terminer sixième de la
finale internationaux organisés au mans
le 15 octobre dernier pour nous parler à
de ce résultat nous avons le plaisir de
recevoir sur ce plateau
la nouvelle pépite du karting français
hadji milhas déjà champion de france et
son père à cyril elias bonsoir bon alors
je le disais super sixième place de
jimmy roman magnifique magnifique on est
vraiment impressionné par ce résultat
donc il y avait les meilleurs pilotes
mondiaux donc 41 nations représentées et
donc j'imitais le plus jeune a 9 ans et
1 mois à 9 ans âgé de 8 ans 9 ans et 1
mois et donc la plupart des pilotes
avaient entre 11 et 13 ans donc très
grande performance de jim très très
grande performance
jimmy est ce que tu t'attendais à
réussir à résultat comme celui là bas
pas du tout et bah je le réussis du coup
je suis très fier et comment t'as fait
selon toi pour réussir ce résultat bah
je me suis concentré j'ai bien pris mais
les trajectoires et c'est venu tout seul
vous l'aviez préparé cette course cyril
avec lui mais alors vraiment emballé non
on a eu d'inscription 48 heures avant la
course
quarante huit heures aurait donc c'est
le seul regret qu'on a ces deux on n'a
pas pu on a été inscrit vraiment in
extrémiste au dernier moment en droit
c'est un peu compliqué pour des
histoires de licence et que mancini
était très jeune et de qualification
sans bon
c'était un peu un peu rude mais on a
quand même réussi à avoir cette
inscription donc je pense que nous
serons pas de repérage e circuit rien du
tout avant malheureusement non parce que
c'est une catégorie que du mit découvrez
un nouveau moteur un nouveau châssis des
nouveaux pneumatiques donc
malheureusement
il ya des gens qui préparent cette
course depuis un an donc on a tous
découvert sur place jimmy bravo parce
que
tout découvrir comme ça dans une
catégorie e
beaucoup plus rapide que celle voyez
d'habitude je pense que c'est si on
avait pu préparer
je pense qu'il aurait joué la gagne
jamie est ce que tu penses que tu aurais
pu faire mieux ton papa le disait tu
aurais peut-être plus jouer la gagne si
tu avais été mieux préparé est-ce que tu
aurais pu faire mieux bah oui quand huit
heures avant c'est difficile de se
préparer et 6 ch aurait ainsi je me
serai préparé avant j'aurais peut-être
pu enfin le podium ont gagné qu'est-ce
qui doit améliorer encore jimmy dans sa
façon de conduire alors dans la gestion
du quartier - m on va dire que en france
le règlement est très stricte il on
parlera au contact c'est vraiment de
très très réglementés
à l'international les cours sont plus
violentes il ya des boîtes il ya des
petits coups de pontons les gamins sont
beaucoup plus agressifs et donc je pense
juste un petit peu plus d'agressivité et
je pense que ça aurait pu faire des
sciences alors tu as eu la chance
d'avoir comme supporters esteban au pont
le pilote de formule 1 qui pilote sur
force india pourquoi pourquoi est il
venu sur le circuit mini bain pour me
donner beaucoup de conseils et me faire
progresser encore plus si tu as donné
comme conseils par exemple où il faut
passer il faut freiner plus tard comme
celle-ci simpara coach aussi pour toi
cyril il aide beaucoup à esteban au
conte bouffandeau jamie lewis
extraordinaire esteban ocon gelé connu
davantage de jimmy
il était déjà très impressionnant
esteban quand il a commencé il a enfin
c'est un diamant pur quoi je veux dire
il a il est vraiment très très fort non
même dans sa connaissance du sport auto
dans la gestion de la course
il a énormément jimmy il donne des
conseils enfin mieux on peut pas faire
je pense c'est vrai que c'est vraiment
le grand pilote français je pense
qu'aujourd'hui fait partie des meilleurs
pilotes mondiaux donc c'est un honneur
de l'avoir à nos côtés lui son papa qui
sont des amis en plus mais il nous donne
un vrai vrai vrai coup de main c'est
extraordinaire j'ai mis quelle est la
prochaine étape pour toi parce qu'ils te
donne envie
déjà champion du monde de karting et
après être en formule 1 est en formule 1
alors tu es fan je crois de lewis
hamilton
estevan au pont aussi faut il vaut mieux
vu que c'est son coach mais c'est vrai
que alors tout petit lewis hamilton et
quand il a vu la progression d'esteban
enfin c'est vrai que bon aujourd'hui
c'est il suit vraiment esteban il et il
est très impressionné par parce qu'il
est très talentueux qui ont pu ce sont
par un sportif mais voilà c'est vraiment
un très bon modèle produit merci à tous
les deux d'être placé sur ce plateau
entre souhaite évidemment j'ai mis
beaucoup de réussite à l'avenir est
d'être champion du monde en prend à
présent la direction de guyancourt pour
la troisième année d'affilée une course
solidaire était organisée à jeudi
dernier aux étangs de la minière ce
challenge avait pour objectif de
récolter des fonds en faveur de deux
associations les restos du coeur et joël
est pour anaëlle la course se proposait
une marche de 6 km une course à pied de
8 km un trail de 10 km sur un tracé en
pleine nature
l'événement réunit plus de 330
participants dont la plupart sont venus
d'une dizaine d'entreprises
on écoute l'un des organisateurs il ya
des sportifs là qui sont habitués à
faire des compétitions des marathons
voire au dessus et il ya aussi un
challenge un peu interentreprises
puisqu'on a aussi la participation de
des entreprises comme renault on à
baxter on a à la saur voilà il ya tout
un tas de l'entreprise qui sont venus se
greffer sur ce sur cet événement qui à
l'origine était parti de chez nous chez
sodexo
l'événement a permis de récolter plus de
5000 euros en faveur de des deux
associations une quatrième édition sera
programmé à l'année prochaine
on passe maintenant notre page agenda
[Musique]
cap sur l'océan dans ce set fidh sport
le skipper versailles et à tanguy de
lamotte prendra le départ de la 13 ème
édition de la transat jacques vabre 5
novembre prochain sur son imoca une
initiative coeur une aventure
transatlantique entre le port du havre
et le brésil qu'il partagera en duo avec
la navigatrice samantha davies pour la
dernière course de sa carrière tanguy de
lamotte espère terminer dans le top 5 du
classement grâce à son nouveau bateau
équipé de foils les ailes profil et qui
se déplace dans l'eau qui permet d'aller
plus vite on écoute le skipper il ya
cinq bateaux qui auront des folles donc
on vise d'être dans ce groupe là et si
possible d'être sur le podium
on se connaît bien avec samantha parce
que c'est donc la deuxième fois qu'on
fait la course ensemble donc on a
beaucoup travaillé cette année on s'est
entraîné avec les meilleurs donc on vise
ont visé une belle performance sur sur
cette course pour pour être au niveau de
notre bateau et du travail qu'on a
fourni
on referme ce magazine par du cyclisme
le prochain tour de france sera de
passage dans les yvelines le tracé de la
105e grande boucle a été dévoilée mardi
dernier la compétition se déroulera du 7
au 29 juillet 2018 dernière étape au
départ de houille le département qui
accueille donc de nouveau l'ultime étape
cinq ans après versailles au programme
115 km pour rejoindre le grand final des
champs-elysées à paris
et puis on l'a appris à vendredi dernier
les yvelines accueilleront les
championnats de france de cyclisme sur
route du 28 juin au 1er juillet c'est
sur la commune de mantes-la-jolie que
seront installés la ligne de départ et
d'arrivée du rendez vous nous aurons
l'occasion d'en parler dans un prochain
à 7,8 sport c'est la fin de ce magazine
merci d'avoir suivi très belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]